[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys and today we
have
yoshi in the scene oh wow
did you see our video and then you're
just like man i haven't been on the show
in a minute that's exactly what i did i
texted bart i was like hey bro i see you
talking about me yep sexy boy it looks
like it doesn't bring me around though
so contextualize this for people who
don't know what happened so we were
talking about yoshi about uh one of the
sexiest guys in the world the other
sexiest guy in the world is his brother
yeah okay so the two twenty two the two
sexiest guy in the world was your
brother mario mario that's exactly right
no he writes me um that's a different
story we're just talking about how sexy
he is and then uh he texts me and he
goes hey i need to go
and refute all the things you're talking
i need to challenge my your sexy
that's what you said it wasn't true i
don't even remember this so-called free
giving i didn't we didn't get free [ __ ]
when that fever dream of his you think i
think so
you call you looking at my face right
now call me a [ __ ] liar wait what i'm
just calling you a liar
god damn it let's play the video that
was on instagram
so the video that was on instagram
is instagram has no idea i have no idea
and i would imagine some people maybe
don't we were talking about hot people
privileges that's what it was
all right so so this is the video all
right if you guys are on our instagram
we're posting again so follow us on just
kidding news on instagram maybe we'll
put the video
that was crazy
cute
[Laughter]
[Music]
they kept giving us free [ __ ]
they just kept giving us oh here here's
this
just because yoshi was like such a
sweetheart and he's the hottest guy
either of the sudarsos yeah they they
have like she's not fair it's not fair
oh yeah look at bart he's still
fantastic
this is um yoshi and peter's the
brothers okay thanks ryan for that sex
magnets
they want to [ __ ] each other they're so
hot that's my favorite line yeah they're
so high little [ __ ] each other man
got it so he saw this vid clip
caught up
right and you know what the tease is
yeah they're so hot they want to [ __ ]
each other but they never have yeah
that's
just he's in us about that problem
like people are waiting on that content
they're saying that's
i think that's the kind of work meetings
i like to come to
we gotta fill steve in about all this
stuff yeah which gum you talking about
yeah why haven't you [ __ ] your brother
that was also brought up in the middle
of us talking about like cnn plus
shutting down yeah that was a video on
seven flights
oh that's how they tied together what
happens we were talking about cnn plus
that we just saw nick shaking like he
wanted to bring something up and we like
what would you like to say okay i'll say
it i'll say it but we were talking about
good looking people
always have it easier yeah because for
whatever reason or something and then
nick talks about how like yeah like
yoshi my good looking friend you know we
get free [ __ ] yeah so you have no
recollection of that moment no i don't
really i feel like we paid for it all
the time right i'm pretty sure we paid
for everything i hope there's a jk fan
out there who's like i really want to
hear their take on cnn plus quickly
finally
[Laughter]
i didn't talk about it at all the video
clauses they're just sitting there in
silence
so we've got the facts down cnn plus
doesn't matter yoshi's hot he hasn't
[ __ ] his brother yet and now he's here
so when are you
what's with the what's with the yet
that's not happening that's what he's
talking about
what makes you take a shirtless picture
with your brother like that
without making it
listen we are very comfortable in our
masculinity that i'm okay with doing
that with all of you guys
masculinity
masculinity uh i'm down to do that with
all of you i thought i don't know if it
was you but someone told me right that
you guys started trolling
doing like gay photo shoots together
right
pretty like um
no they started doing these seductive
like
pictures that were like it was funny
because you guys are brothers but you
know so you guys were like we'll get you
and you guys built the whole fan base
and and they got a huge gay following
is that how it started
i mean i don't know if that because you
guys are all modeling sites and stuff
too right no but their pictures were so
funny though because it was like really
sexual
i remember you guys were mermaids one
time and i was like yeah do that and
there was like five of us four of us
merman sorry merman
whatev whatever you want to call it
doesn't matter were they what were they
uncool basically became eye candy for
all these dudes and then so half of your
following or some [ __ ] like that became
like huge right i think if i look at my
ellie's instagram um and like twitter
it's like maybe
70 80 percent dudes
oh
easier to sell ads you know uh because
i'm selling shirts that are for men and
it says lover brothers
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
if i'm gay i just say like nine percent
you know
just nine you're only married
there's spectrum to this
when did you first find out you were gay
nine percent gay five percent no did you
guys knew you guys were hot brothers in
my second grade
bro i had headgear i had
my my mouth was like all messed up i had
headgear that i had to pull down oh wow
my teeth were like this and it came to a
point until
uh i fell on a stunt when i like did a
job you know back in the day and that's
why
uh no universal studios tell them the
story dude
you can watch davidson's thing we did a
whole thing on that [ __ ] they don't
watch david
let them stay here we don't want them to
cook away well it was water world this
was it back in 2011 or something i had
already started getting into like
commercials acting or whatever
and i got it
i couldn't get any roles as an asian guy
so i went into stunts and i did a live
show it was called water world and i
remember because my first headshot my
teeth were like this i couldn't even
close my mouth even after five years of
braces and headgear couldn't close my
mouth your bite was like this yeah yeah
like it would uh what it's not called
yeah overview and that by the way had
nothing to do with you not getting rolls
possibly
had nothing to do with it possibly
also probably the fact that i was an
asian dude
there was no roles and i didn't have any
rep all the asian 2011 yeah nah there
was nothing it was nothing it was you
guys it was you guys that's the only
times i got anything my first like
acting job was with you guys all the
rules were going to underbite guys
[Laughter]
my teeth were so overbite when i fell i
hit the water 45 feet into water and i
hit the water like this and my teeth
just went whack right underneath and it
cracked the whole top six so they all
fell off i came out i was like
yo my tu my tongue feels weird they're
like what
all my teeth came out and i was like oh
god
bleeding like immediately there was no
blood it was just because it was still
bone it wasn't like it broke your teeth
just broke my teeth and it didn't hurt
it hurt it hurt but i was like more like
the bruising in my chest but then did
you say ego i shot my teeth out i was
like
like ooh like right and the wind hit my
nerves oh
i buckled to the floor i was like oh my
god
was that a
fall like
gone wrong so it was supposed to be
the idea is is i was doing rehearsal and
and it's the character that gets lit on
fire and he runs around
at the top and he falls 45 feet to his
death right death in the water
so because the fire is behind you you
have to run a certain way and you have
to fall a certain way the fall is called
a a step off branny a brownie is a
like half twist front flip right you're
supposed to step off and then you do a
brandy because you want to stay like
this fire behind you you fall as you get
to here you want to twist and then that
way the fire stays behind you as you're
coming down and you fall on your feet
but they taught me a little bit weird
and i was new i've never done diving
before i just was like yeah i'll do it
whatever
and i twisted like
hella fast and i because i took off with
the left leg instead of my right leg
they said it was a cartwheel not a
brownie so i did a cartwheel i should
have done a brand new with my left uh
right foot and twist left but i twisted
hella fast somebody has this on video
too one of my buddies filming it
wow
flat on my face
and from 45 feet to the water from 45
feet that's like concrete so this was
all like purple like for the next few
days or whatever but it was mostly
because i hit like this
and my teeth because it was like that if
it was here it would have been fine but
it went clap
if you're crying
into the water can people tell you
bro apparently
apparently that story is still going
around because i'm the only one who's
ever broken my teeth on that fall wow
[Applause]
but then universal paid for the new
beautiful smile
and now i can close my mouth today's
video is brought to you by faridy
man every single time i go out
uh i look like i'm going to the beach
whether i'm in the desert mountains or
anywhere i kind of have this casual look
to myself
uh
thank goodness ferrari came around
because you know i feel like their
clothes is like ready for the beach but
also
it feels a little bit more expensive you
know what i mean yeah it's like high
quality look at this t-shirt
this is a high quality t-shirt a nice
collar it's nice and thick look at these
shorts man i'm gonna wear this like
every day i could wear in the beach but
also at a restaurant
in hawaii and they look like really
timeless designs you know like where you
wear it won't look like you go out of
style
luckily ferdi makes it way easier they
make the perfect clothes for all seasons
they do fairy is a family run brand
making high quality timeless clothing
with modern design and functionality
it's that kind of effortless style you
want every time you go digging in your
closet that set that shirt that dress
that feels like you had them for years
maybe it's in a gorgeous print and it
looks like it might be vintage but it
fits so well it feels like it was made
just yesterday look at this just for you
me well that's very look at that and
faraday is so confident in the quality
of their stuff they have a lifetime
guarantee of their quality wow they'll
replace or fix your clothes forever no
matter what talk about making it easier
to get dressed and right now faraday is
giving all off the record listeners
twenty percent off twenty percent off
wow
head to
record and use the code off the record
at checkout is snag 20 off all your new
spring staples that's called off the
record at faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y-brand.com
off the record for 20 off
veritybrand.com
off the record wow wow those uh what
would they call them veneers so it was
veneers and some of them were um what is
it the uh
crowns oh crowns i think is what it's
called and then i was sparring with
david i was about to tell you i'll tell
you like you better tell the story next
about what about like david so being a
bully bro david
thinks he's or he says he's bad he
[ __ ] sandbags like he's a sandbagger
he's a sandbag he's a lot better than he
says
yeah oh okay you know what i mean
and he'll go like you want we'll go
light we'll go light and he hits you and
then he immediately turns it up he's got
heavy you know how strong he is yeah he
thinks he's a little [ __ ] he's tall
he's big his reach is like twice of my
reach
he was popping me in the face and i i
leaned into it and we were i didn't wear
a mouth guard because we were going
light like that's what he calls it
clack and i was like oh
oh there goes my veneer
and you had an audition that day right i
did and then bro i lived with that
chipped tooth for like
maybe a year and a half because it
happened and i was like i'm wearing
masks oh [ __ ]
so i just didn't do anything about it
was it like a front tooth like it was
the this one right here oh no the front
two do you guys think that david does
that just so he can look tougher
i would do
i'd be like yeah we're going to spar
okay
and david's like what are you tripping
about i didn't [ __ ] hit you that hard
he gaslights everybody i was already
losing everyone that's has sparred with
them has felt that but like come on
david what the [ __ ] and his his reaction
all the time what yeah what my favorite
moment was going with him and i remember
him hitting me in the body with his like
leg hits he just like [ __ ]
roundhouses all day and he would go
gotta block that gotta block that i'm
like
i know [ __ ] stop kicking me there
did universal pick up the tab for your
veneers you did yeah they did they did
take care of did you go back to doing
water world after that
no yeah i did that was my first day it
was rehearsals i hadn't even done
it was like day five of rehearsals and
we finally got to the top because we
were doing the smaller ones and we had
at the top and like
we had been talking the cameras were off
right now was it a con
you're like yo i gotta need
[Laughter]
how long did it take for you to heal to
go back on the show oh bro i uh so it
happened on a friday i went to the
doctors that day to make sure nothing
was broken and then they sent me to the
dentist that day
and then they put fake whatever in my
mouth it was like just like crappy old
ones that pop off every little chicklets
yeah and it would like pop up but it was
like together it was all six it was
weird i felt like an old man and then
the next day or that night i went to go
watch one of the shows of the other
performers and i saw one of the guys do
it and i was like
he's using his other leg and he's
twisting the same way i am
he i've been doing it all wrong so the
next day i went to geo the gymnastics
olympic i was like where you would go
and i would jump on a trampoline and try
to do it so it was like the next day i
just kept going were you injured at the
time like bruises and [ __ ] yeah whatever
i was like i needed to i was young i was
like i'm gonna get this done i don't
want to look stupid i felt bad stunt
guys are also built different though i
felt so bad she's like a self-taught
stunt guy too yeah the [ __ ] i've seen
this guy do is insane bro are you still
doing stunts no i stopped like a few
years ago yeah it hurts i got a kid now
we shot this skit um with uh was it
benji benjamin
this white dude that looked like uh
justin bieber
oh yeah yeah yeah and like we would we
were like we're down to cheat some shots
yeah and we're supposed to like drive a
car or whatever adam he goes no no i'll
just flip over it and then it's like
these are you oh bin jinx yeah yeah
these are like youtube oh he's like top
number one in the world for for that
kind of stuff like no union we don't got
insurance or nothing like that and
they're just so [ __ ] down we'll do it
over do it over and over they'll do like
10 of them over and over and over
hitting him with the car i've heard of
you a lot through these guys some people
are yeah gangster man never doing that
again that's one of the things like why
don't you do your own stunts i'm like i
did other people why would i do my own
now
that's true
what would i do i mean you know how like
sometimes we all you know turn passion
into work right there is a point where
it gets to be work right so like what
was that moment for you when you're just
like damn bro like
i gotta get somebody else to do this
[ __ ] for me like stunts was with the
thing with stunts is it's very
consistent and as an asian guy it was
very like a lot easier to well i guess
not so much easy but easier to get work
than acting oh there just wasn't space
for us you always need asian guys to
beat up anyways right they want all
these ninjas right but again
if you're an asian fight guy living in
la you better be top tier or you're not
going to work oh you have to be the top
of the game because there's so much
other guys if if you're you know if
you're white or you're black not to
discount them but
there's less competition and less of
that is going to go around and if you're
an asian guy you have like that's just
an expectation is there like more asians
in the stunt world is that why like
there's more competition by side yes
like there are like seven asian drivers
now so they they work all the time with
driving but then when it comes to fights
there's so many of you throw a rock and
find a really good one oh
yeah unfortunately that's like the case
they would sell it
[Laughter]
this rise of like asian men specifically
in media like i was like i'm gonna go
into acting and and it came to a point
where i was like i no longer need to do
stunts for money you know what was that
for you uh power rangers that was the
first role but when i came back i got i
finally got a manager an agent so i kept
doing stunts because i loved it i
enjoyed it but it was mostly uh when i
had silas when i had a kid i was like
it's not worth it for me to go out there
and risk my life
because there are still some like it's
pretty safe nowadays but there are still
some jobs that you're like
i could have died doing a sex scene is
much more safer unless you get mono what
do you mean it's pretty safe nowadays
versus like what it was before
man back in the day it used to be like
cowboys and they would just throw
themselves off horses and stuff like
that there was no safety that's when it
started right yeah back in the day like
even the old school like stunt
coordinators were pretty like
just get out there and do it you know
like you want to pat up the floor for me
like we're not seeing the floor that's
what unions ruin everything
but now they have stuff like uh high
dense foam that they can print stuff
onto so it looks like carpet or the yeah
the wall oh
they did that for the matrix a bunch i
saw that in the behind the scenes yeah
and that's because like those guys uh
that train with like
dude they used to be the [ __ ] guy
yeah and there used to be the guys who
hit the ground so it's like if they used
to hit the ground they know that that
sucks so if we can fix it why not
and then there are the other guys were
like we had to do this so why don't you
just do it it's not even in the shot
right exactly
did you guys see the new matrix movie
yeah
the fights compared to the ones that yen
wu ping did it's like oh it's it's like
amateur hour dude it's like power
rangers honestly versus
it is versus what they used to do with
putty guys oh dude what they did with
the [ __ ] matrix trilogy
what's crazy is if you actually look
back on the ranger stuff
now like
watch the ranger stunts that they do
you'll take your your word back for that
i don't think because it's crazy they
jump off of like buildings and hit
straight up concrete i mean the japanese
ones yeah yeah oh
dress so silly i can't take it seriously
for a second
but i think you just proved to everybody
made it worse
i'm refuting the fact that we got free
[ __ ] because of that but not the
brotherly love part right no no not at
all i love my brother everyone's nicer
to us when you're around i'll say that
are you going to come on next time be
like i want to prove i'm a [ __ ] and
then then you're like yeah i got all
bruised up and i went that night i went
the next day
so what was the place you guys went to
where you got free [ __ ] some like
chinese spot
and the bill
was not that what it was really like a
mall food court there was samples
he just thinks they were given a free
shipping what if it's because they're
like oh you're the blue ranger i'm
laying a blue rifle yeah dude did we
really yeah bro you don't remember this
dude you don't think
this happens to you probably he's used
to that life it's i'm not used to this
so i was like this isn't enough he's
like a hot girl that's like i don't know
why guys are so nice
everyone's so nice to me everyone's so
nice to to yoshi when he's around for
sure wait wait wait yeah everyone
everyone's nice to me when i'm around
yeah yeah and when you're not around
yeah that is what i said yoshi's like a
chick with big tits yeah yeah what do
you mean i'm i'm a dude with big tits
mike was good he got some fat tits on
you i'm working on it i'm trying
to see that picture again throw it up
yeah
right here with your brother
i'm trying you guys
you